by now you have had enough time to burn
through the second season of stranger
things if not here's your spoiler
warning if you have binge your way
through stranger things too you might be
holding on to some nagging questions
after that final episode sure it was a
great ending but did it clear up
everything not even close
here are some of the biggest questions
we wish stranger things to had answered
lost sister in Chapter 7 the lost sister
we finally meet the mysterious girl from
the season starred Kali 11 sister but
not really from the Hawkins lab like 11
Kylie manifests paranormal abilities and
can make people see anything she wants
11 burns through a rebellious streak and
finally realizes that home is back in
Hawkins with her friends so what
happened to Kali and her weird little
gang after opening the season on these
guys and then devoting an entire episode
to them there's no follow-up whatsoever
evil dr. Brenner
one of the big reveals in Chapter 7 was
the fact that dr. brenner the evil
scientist from season 1 is alive after
all xi and kali tracked down ray the guy
who zapped Elevens mother and just as
they're about to lay down the hurt
Graner I can take you to
is gone no he is a lie
but since Brenner never appears the
flesh fans can only wonder was Ray
telling the truth or was he lying to
them to buy himself some time
unfortunately the show drops the
questions of Brenner's whereabouts after
11 hallucination so we never do find out
for sure if the doc survived the
demagogue on in season 1 while we're on
the topic of nefarious scientists nice
dr. Owens somewhere in the chaotic good
area of the moral scale some scenes see
dr. Owens doing his best to help will
hopper in the gang even going so far as
to speak out against eradicating the
tunnel gross while they still can affect
will but we also see him clandestinely
monitoring all these people he's
supposedly helping one thing to keep in
mind is that even casting decisions hold
some weight for these characters and
Owens is played by Paul Reiser who
played a similarly not-so-good good guy
in aliens considering that the duffer
brothers love aliens and wrote dr. Owens
with riser in mind to play the part
there's probably a lot more to the guy
than we've seen and then there's Owen
surviving the demo dog infestation at
Hawkins lab even the military guys with
guns didn't stand a chance even Bob
didn't stand a chance and he was the
best mr. mom Oh Anne Owens managed to
escape with a leg wound color as
suspicious and now were not even letting
the fact that Owens very nicely doctored
up a birth certificate 411 change or
mind
there's just something about that guy he
figured that he could get an alien back
through quarantine if one of us was
impregnated
whatever you call it oh yeah that's it
the shadow monster sure that gave it
plenty of names like the shadow monster
and the mind flare but what is that big
leggy thing specifically we know it's
connected to the rest of the organisms
that come out of the upside-down but the
closest thing we get to a backstory for
the shadow monster is Dustin's Dungeons
& Dragons analogy it's so ancient and it
doesn't even know its true home
okay Aiden slaves races about the
dimensions by kicking over their brains
using its highly developed psionic
powers but since that's only an analogy
it still doesn't explain anything about
the actual shadow monster threatening
Hawkins and big surprise neither does
the show all we know is that it's
probably pretty mad since it basically
just got shoved out of an
all-you-can-eat buffet looks like we'll
have to wait until season 3 for this one
infection while chief hopper is
exploring the underground tunnels in
Chapter five he discovers some weird new
organisms from the upside down including
a flower that sneezes right in his face
two of them in fact later the same thing
happens to Dustin but what did those
flowers spray on them and are they now
infected with something because there is
some precedent for people in Hawkins
acting as incubators for other critters
well it's not exactly the same hoppers
episode is reminiscent of what happened
to will buyers in season one when Hopper
and Joyce found will in the upside down
in the season finale will had a vine
like thing rammed down his throat a
couple of months later will choked out a
slug that slithered down the drain
similarly elevenses the same kind of
slug crawl out of Barb's mouth when she
finds her body in the upside-down
flash-forward again - season 2 and
Dustin finds a slug in his trash can
that looks a lot like those other slugs
just with feet when will sees it even as
a flashback to that slimy Christmas
surprise is Dustin's pet Dart the same
slug or at least the same species that
seems to be the take away which means
that we'll had a baby Demma dog living
in him for a while so is there something
inside of hopper now and if so what is
it is dart ademma Gorgon during the
season we see a creature grow from a
slug with legs to a Demma dog in a
ridiculously short amount of time
then the dog face seems to be the cap at
this point but those faces sure look
familiar don't they it begs the question
after spending some time on four legs to
the demo dog's multi Ganon eventually
turn into full-sized Emma Gorgons
there's no real reason to assume they do
it's totally understandable for
different creatures with the same messed
up face to live in the upside down but
admit it as soon as you saw dart eating
Dustin's cat there was only one word on
your mind the show never confirms
whether or not dark actually is the same
species as the monster from season one
and even though the easy answer is yes
there's nothing to confirm that either
way mystery eggs come on we've waited a
whole year to find out what those eggs
from season 1 were and got zero answers
in the new season in light of all the
new information about the upside-down
including what may be an entire multi
species ecosystem we were really hoping
for those eggs to get an explanation do
the demo Corgan's eat them do they lay
them like big scary chickens what
hatched out of the one hopper found we
just have a million questions about
those eggs and we cordially request some
answers missing Yertle by the end of the
season most of the characters are
checked off and accounted for but
there's one more character still missing
that nobody seems to be asking about
when Dustin finds teensy little darkness
Trash Can he takes his turtle out of its
cage to give dart a home sorry Yertle
temporary eviction buddy
eventually little dark turns out to be a
killer pre demo dog and after that it's
a whirlwind of hockey pads and
nail-studded baseball bats as Dustin and
Steve try to track down the rogue Demma
dog but what about the turtle did dark
eat the turtle or is it just gathering
dust bunnies under Dustin's bed this is
clearly the question on everyone's mind
and if it isn't why not
you monster thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
youtube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]